so recently there's an article on the
news about a computer which had sold for
$200,000 the computer itself an Apple
one built by Steve Wozniak back in the
70s had originally only sold for 666
dollars but a woman had taken it to a
recycling center and effectively thrown
it away the company is now trying to
attract the woman so they can share the
profits they've made from selling it but
just why was this computer so special
and what was it made of so the story of
the Apple 1 takes us back to the West
Coast in the mid 70s Steve Wozniak was
happily working at HP designing
calculators and he went along to one of
the early meetings of the homebrew
Computer Club where he thought he's
going to talk about TV terminals and
being able to connect to the ARPANET for
a TV but actually everyone was talking
about the cover of popular electronics
where the MIT's Altair 8800 had just
appeared on the cover it was probably
the first computer that used a
microprocessor as its CPU rather than
building it discreetly out of logic
chips if you learn more about it click
here we're Jason at the Center for
computing history in Cambridge we'll
explain there as they have a serial
number three wasn't you hadn't even
heard of these CPUs at the time but was
interested and he was given a data sheet
for the 8080 which was at the heart of
the machine and took it home and began
to look over it and he realizes it was
very similar to a computer he'd built
previously out of discrete logic
components which he called the cream
solar computer because he'd built it out
of cream soda cans for the case so he
started looking at this and very quickly
realized that he could design a computer
based around this using very few chips
and the CPU some Ram some ROM and put it
together to build a complete computer
for much less than the cost of the
Altair he then realized he could link it
into a terminal he'd built and a
terminal was just a machine that you
could use to connect to ARPANET through
a normal television which we've done
that ARPANET was the forerunner in those
days over the Internet and so he built
this system that could connect to it
through a cheap domestic television set
rather than having to use lots and lots
of lights on the front of your
to communicate with it just use a
television screen it'd be much easier to
communicate through that and you could
put a proper typewriter keyboard in it
and produce a system so he worked out
these things he reused his circuit
through his television terminal
connected that up to the logic inside
and his CB
his computer he designed put it together
with the keyboard and you've managed to
design he hadn't built it at that point
a complete computer he then looked at
the design and someone who's working
with suggested you looked at the
different CPU called six eight hundred
because it was considerably cheaper and
you could get one as an HP employee for
about forty dollars so we redesigned the
system using that and he also looked at
RAM and he'd originally considered using
what's called static RAM but then
decided because it was cheaper again to
use what's called dynamic RAM when
you've managed to get a good deal on
some dynamic Ram as well so redesign his
circuit and then he'd heard about a new
chip which was the 6502 this chip is
used in lots and lots of computer
systems right through to the mid 80s
things like the BBC micro the Commodore
64 and so on so he redesigned the
circuit again around this all those just
basically plugging in the new chip and
he then went off to build the computer
normally something like the outer and
other computers at that time you would
program them by having switches on the
front to type in the memory locations
and the data that you wanted to store
there what wasn't like realize because
he was working with calculators at the
time with HP is that calculators were
effectively computers to some extent
they had programs they had processors
they did things you put input but the
calculator started up straightaway
because the program was burnt into the
ROM inside it so he programmed his
initial program for the what became the
Apple one into some ROM and put that
into a system so his computer would
start up straightaway with what he
called his monitor program so the user
could see the data on the TV screen and
they could input the data using a
standard keyboard and it's perhaps this
that made the difference between the
Apple one and whatever everything that
followed it and what had come before in
terms of units because before yet you
could plug a keyboard in yep you could
plug a video display in but actually
most of the time you're entering the
data to get it started at least via
the toggles on the front while Steve
Wozniak's his genius moment was was he
actually replaced that with a small bit
of program built into the system and a
video display using a typical telly and
a keyboard for entry so you went from
being some of the only hardware hackers
or perhaps comfortable with to the
forerunner of the PC that we know today
so Steve Wozniak built the the Apple
what became the Apple one for himself
and he took it to the homebrew Computer
Club and started showing it around to
the other people there and of course he
showed it to his friend Steve Jobs and
Steve Jobs realized that while other
people in the computer club were taking
copies and schematics they weren't
actually building it themselves and so
he said to wasn't it
why don't we make up some circuit boards
ourselves and actually sell them to
people they can make their boards for
$20 sell the kits for $40 including all
the components and still make profit
people would see them as a deal because
of getting all the parts and wasn't it
wasn't pups sure at first but Steve Jobs
said to him said look whatever happens
if we fail we can at least have got a
company to our name we have made a
company and wasn't a act like this idea
and so together they started a small
company called Apple so if you want to
find out more about the history of the
Apple one and Apple itself can recommend
two books Steve Wozniak's biography I
was goes into the details about how he
created it and what he was doing at the
time great read and also if you're
interested in the technical side of it
is this book the Apple one replica
creation where Tom over goes into how
you can actually build your own Apple
one goes through how to program it and
so on and looks at the hardware inside
it
both great reads and available from your
unusual book shops